[Music]
okay so
a video went viral recently of a woman
showing us how to make a burrito it's
her burrito recipe
and it went viral and most people were
repulsed and offended by it i thought it
looked
pretty good so i thought we would try to
replicate her recipe i got a few of my
own little ingredients i'm going to toss
into it
i'm something of a chef myself so this
begins with
uh cheese whiz that you just put
that you just put right on oh okay we're
just gonna we're using our hands here
this is this is how she did it
why aren't we using a bowl i don't know
but this is the way it works so we just
and the good thing is you're gonna smell
like like cheese for the rest of the day
so you don't need any cologne
you're gonna smear that all around now
what i like is whatever cleaning
[Music]
substance you use you're gonna get some
of that flavor so it's gonna have a
little bit of bleach that i like in my
food
all right next next
we're going to take some we got the
protein okay so this is all about
health and wellness next we've got the
lettuce so this is what it get we get
really healthy if you're a vegan you're
going to like the fact that we've got
the uh the vegetables in there next we
have black beans
okay this is what i like this is the
thing i thought when i saw this recipe
is that it seemed really healthy uh to
me because we've got all the major
food groups cheese beans vegetables
we're gonna put a little bit of salad
i'm not a big sour cream guy
so i'm putting a little bit and i've
also got a
i'm putting just a little bit of sour
cream that's all i'm doing is just a
little bit what i mean is the entire
thing okay now here's where i'm gonna
put i'm gonna blow your mind a little
bit
this is where i like to throw just a few
we're not gonna overdo it
just a few semi-sweet chocolate chips
okay um because this is something that
people that aren't chefs you don't
realize you want all the flavor profiles
so you've got
uh you've got the meat flavor profile
you've got cheese you've got
uh sweets as well so you're gonna get
all of that it's very complex
but you also need spice so we're gonna
throw some spice in
again we're not over doing it we're just
doing a little bit that's all we're
doing
okay we want the flavors to be very
subtle
and then salsa of course because this is
a respect to the mexican culture they
always put salsa in
i had an aunt who was uh half mexican so
this is part of where i
got this this from now there's not
enough cheese
we're throwing more cheese on that's the
one when you look at this
when you look at this you think this
there's not enough cheese that's the one
thing
that's missing now you see here you see
this green ooze just coming out
that's what you're looking for when
you're making
food now guacamole don't forget that
this is what puts it this is what puts
it over the edge
is this guacamole here so we're just
putting that on
um and taco seasoning okay
this is what's gonna tie it all together
is the seasoning
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
throw a little bit of seasoning
into the green group as well i like for
my green group to have
that seasoning now we also need chips
okay this is going to give it the crunch
so we've got all the flavors we also got
all the textures
so we've got the texture of goopiness
we've got the texture of
meat and then we've got this the crunchy
as well all right we need a way to mix
all this together
now you might think go grab a utensil no
we don't use utensils here
because what if all your utensils are
what if you're at home
and your wife is not there and you don't
have any clean utensils
are you gonna clean your own i don't
think so no you're just gonna use your
hands all right so we're going to do
this we're just mixing it all together
make sure you're not wearing any
clothing that you care about and all of
these smells look all of these smells
are going to be with you for the rest of
the day
so i'm going to smell just absolutely
awful for the entire rest of the day
and that is who
you see this right now and you just
you're feeling real hungry when you look
at this
and here's the great thing it looks the
same
going in as it does coming out so
there's that symmetry
that i really appreciate now
um i like to go real classy so we're
gonna put it in a taco
bowl and uh i think she used an ice
cream scooper
but i say we don't need that because my
hands are already oh i should use ice
cream okay i will use the ice cream
scoop because we're gonna
we're trying to replicate what she did
and we're just gonna put it in like that
okay i'm kind of on a diet so i'm not
gonna overdo it but
we're gonna do that now here's the last
thing you're not gonna expect this
because you see that you think that
looks absolutely delicious it's missing
something i know what it's missing i'll
show you
whipped cream okay and this is what's
going to
bring it all together this is what takes
it from a b-plus dish
to an a-plus all right also
you know it's a little bit more romantic
too so if you're serving this up
for a lady friend maybe valentine's day
uh you put this on the table and she
is gonna have to stop herself from
pouncing on you because she's gonna be
so
turned on by it now um and there it is
there's the uh there's the dish
and this is the part where you know
typically you would take a bite of it
and i you know it's and um
the thing is i forgot that i'm actually
fasting at the moment for the
forgiveness of my sins and does anybody
anybody want to take a bite of this
anyone here i mean it's
did you guys all eat lunch okay well i
mean it does look pretty good so
all right let's take it let's just take
one bite see what it tastes like
i'm just savoring the moment as i'm
doing right now and savoring the moment
thinking about how great this is gonna
taste okay
that's so good